Michael Jackson did diesem and one of my
neighbors was the cameraman for Jermaine
Jack's we don't have a copy of a copy of
a copy of anything original there people
of course call the gospel books Matthew
Mark Luke and John well they call the
Matthew Mark Luke and John because we
don't know who wrote these book God been
there asking but what's the
manifestation of God then they start
going towards the Trinity what do you
like to say when people bring this up
yeah well that's the same argument that
the Hindus make or I mean people are not
even allowed to read the Bible you could
be executed if you were found in the
position of a Bible reading a Bible
could the hidden life of trees if I was
actually part of that group that a
specific restricted group that this this
teacher talks about in this interview
uniquely one
[Music]
assalamualaikum Gabriele Gibril Romani
how are you my brother so we just spoke
a couple days ago and I didn't know you
it was kind of you something came up and
it just put a confirmation on what you
said you removed the doubt that Michael
Jackson indeed accepted Islam Ya Allah I
used to work in the UAE and one of my
neighbors was the cameraman for Jermaine
Jackson yeah so he would he would go and
do some documentaries for him in Africa
so he was the right-hand man for
Jermaine Jackson which is Michael
Jackson brother who is the Muslim of
course and he totally confirmed that he
died as a son you said something about
someone pray Jenna's on him yeah they
pray Jenna's live like any like quite a
few I mean is their prejudice an absence
yeah okay so it's confirmed that he did
die as a Muslim Michael Jackson did die
as a Muslim I mean his brother would
know him the best right Moses person
Jermaine Jackson's yeah Jermaine
Jermaine Jack's this is such an old
topic why are you guys bringing it up
yeah go ahead how did this come up how
did it come up actually I was talking I
was talking to the two Romanians and
then we got you involved we were giving
them some Dawa and then I think one of
the Romanians brought it up because we
were in Indiana yeah and they brought up
my they brought up Michael Jackson this
is the face of Michael Jackson was born
yeah that's how it came out now we
confirmed that he did die as a Muslim
towards his last year's yes and
hamdulillah how you been
I'm Dillon rather can't compare less
than most kind of man yeah so give us a
little bit a bit for those who have seen
you on the Dean show before they know
about you for those who are just tuning
in for the first time tell us a little
about yourself okay spill out come the
allow Allah so my name is Gabriel Armani
from Romania
moved to Canada accepted Islam and the
age of and in 1920 run there just after
9/11 and come to Allah you know did my
studies there and move to the UAE and
work as a teacher and became a school
superintendent principal of Islamic
schools in Sharjah and then now working
in Malaysia as a school principal
400-degree school and Kuala Lumpur and
I've been here for about a year and a
half now how many left and yeah my
background is in biology psychology
neuroscience and cognition as well as
education
and I have a degree in Islamic studies
as well and as I said working as an
educational consultant around the world
and as a counsellor for youth and you
know different families marriage divorce
all these things some Leila you also
specialized in one form of the Dawa
where you were refuting many of the
attacks the false accusations the
misrepresentations that many people with
some nefarious agendas were trying to
create confusion in the Muslim world and
you would go out and you would you would
specifically study these areas and
refute these things is that correct yes
so we started the ICR in Davao a.org
2009 around there thousand and ten and
but before that we were you know doing
this anyway but it became an actual
organization Islamic Centre for research
and academics and our speciality is in
writing articles refuting Orientalist
specifically orientalist and you know
academic articles responding to the
major allegations against the snap such
as that the Quran is corrupt such as the
prof salsalin who had you know different
kind of lifestyle and jihad and all
these things that you know the common
things that you're here Islamophobe or
whatever you want to call it with try to
use against Islam to get Muslims to
leave Islam so one of our courses is
called defense against disaster ok
defense against this
from your demeanor on these books our
Salmonella wasup lost middle class and
this is basically defense against
disaster
meaning apostasy so it's called defense
against intellectual apostasy where we
train different community leaders to
understand how to defend their community
against intellectual apostasy attacks
from different you know different
mission areas and different liberals and
people are trying to systematically no
doubt and it's there it's not some kind
of conspiracy policy or conspiracy
theory it is happening it's been
happening for for quite some time now
and sadly the Muslim Ummah is sleeping
so yeah we focused on writing these
articles I think I can confidently say
that we've reviewed at every single
allegation major allegation that exists
out there against the Quran Sunnah
against the prophets and in his life and
and so on and where can people read
these articles and these reputations
where can they go again yeah I see are
double a.org I see are double a.org so
you'll find all the articles there
there's a section for the Quran there's
a section for some that hadith there's a
section for the life of the process and
specific about marriage and his wife's
and his personal life so of course
people love to get involved in in the
personal life of people you know to to
shoot the messenger and you only shoot
the message right yes so always this
discrediting and trying to as they say
poison the well it's a fallacy actually
about this it's not the poison well now
you yourself I mean you went against all
odds I mean coming from a Romanian
background there's more Orthodox
Christian is that correct yeah I mean it
was quite a mixed family but yeah our
background is Orthodox funny enough we
were baptized in three churches in the
Orthodox and Catholic and the Unitarian
three Church job yeah a funny thing is
that recently I had done some some
research on my the name of my family and
Kenneth nish
were Crusaders Karen sessions
specifically the name chemists ish means
the Crucifier or Crusader so there are a
night order Crusader there's even a
battle the Battle of Kadesh between the
Ottomans and the Hungarian Knights so
interesting family background yeah so
you really did your research I mean to
confirm that I mean the the first part
is very simple to understand that you
negate that there aren't any other gods
except the one God that you don't
worship your desires money fame your
ideas human being a messenger a saint
and that you agree what's in your very
nature you testify today and then
Muhammad peace and blessings be upon him
is the last and final messenger sent to
mankind the same testimony that she
would make during the time of Jesus that
there's no other God except the One God
and Jesus is the messenger who was at
his time and Moses at his time but today
the final messenger prophet Muhammad
peace and blessings be upon him who was
a mercy was sent as a mercy to all to
the to everybody who's on the earth
today you confirmed it hundred percent
this was not just an this was not just
an emotional decision you studied looked
at the Quran you looked at the evidence
you looked at the life of Muhammad and
you made that decision that there's no
doubt that this this is indeed from the
creator of the heavens and earth and he
is a messenger who was sent for all of
mankind now the Quran some of these have
you seen some of these attacks that are
the is this something new now these
arguments that are coming up what are
some of the arguments and that are
trying they're trying to create some
confusion here with the Quran trying to
compare it somewhat like the Bible we
know that the Bible we don't have a copy
of a copy of a copy of anything original
there people of course call the gospel
books Matthew Mark Luke and John
well they call the Matthew Mark Luke and
John because we don't know who wrote
these books and there's no point calling
them Sam Fred Jerry and Harry I mean
they're they're written by people we
don't know who they were written by they
are anonymous you might not think so
because they have the title the Gospel
according to Matthew whoever put that
title on it was an editor later the
followers of Jesus were Aramaic speaking
peasants from Galilee lower-class men
who were not educated in fact Peter and
John in Acts
chapter 4 verse 13 are literally said to
be illiterate they couldn't read and
write of course not there were fishermen
they didn't go to school the vast
majority of people in the ancient world
never learned to read let alone write
and their native language was Aramaic
these books are written in Greek by
highly educated rhetorically trained
writers who are skilled in Greek
composition it's no disrespect to the
Bible or anybody out there just relaying
the facts Bible academics tell us this
but what are some of the arguments that
some of these recently some of these
missionaries have been making yeah well
first and foremost as you said I
confirmed that there is no God except
God there's no deity worthy of worship
except God and that's been always the
people have to understand they need to
kind of step back from a lot of these
complicated arguments and just look at
the basics first and foremost right like
you cannot understand equations
quadratic equations unless you know
basic arithmetic you need to understand
that one plus one plus one equals two
three in other mean you need to
understand that it's just basic so the
constant has always been there is no god
but God or no deity but God one God
okay the first commandment says that I
am your Lord thy God thou shalt have no
gods except me on heaven where Jesus is
right now supposed a right and heaven on
earth or anyone who claims today to be
God on earth then there's quite a lot
that's why I tell it guys you guys have
to you guys have to take a stand in line
you know because a lot of claimants out
there or in-between Allah says or in
between so in heaven on earth or in
between right so it eliminates the
possibility of anyone that's what tokine
means in the first place so it's always
been like that it's always been that
there's one God so it's it was the
variable the variable what changed was
that there were different prophets and
messenger there are also different laws
and different types of worship so it was
la ilaha illallah Adam Rasul Allah and
it was la ilaha ilallah no rasulullah
and then it was la ilaha illallah
Ebrahim Rasool Allah and then it was
like ah Suleiman Suleiman
Sarala and finally muhammad rasool allah
allah and upon all of them made the
peace and blessings of god be upon him
as allah Samantha says surah bakra land
of ar-raqqah Baena had no Vasu we make
no distinction upon any of these
messengers they're all messages from God
so when people look at that there's a
continuation as a connection in this
universe between every single prophet
and every single human being mankind
will all unite mankind will only unite
when they submit to God you'll never
solve their problems of racism like you
know what we have right now go around
the states okay George Floyd you're
never gonna solve the problems the
mankind will never solve economic
problems mankind will never solve the
war and violence that takes place except
when they unite and they will never be
able to unite except understand because
Islam is the only one that says there's
no one better than anyone else except
through piety
there is no skin colour there's no
social status there's no education there
is not you want to be the best then show
God okay no don't fight with each other
don't be racist don't nothing okay we
know very well the first incident racism
was between the devil and Adam and he
told Allah and a high you may know I'm
better than him you created me from fire
came from from dirt substance right
that's the first this that's the first
that the original sin you know if you
might say the first sin you know one
this among between adamant and and this
jinn this Satan was that and ifs love
solves all these problems brother you
know brothers and sisters Islam
so-called only people with open up their
minds a bit and try to understand so
when I made my decision see people and I
want people not to be emotional you
can't be emotion you have to be very
rational
even though emotions are important but
when a person
embraces Islam what's so sorry to say
what's so amazing from a worldly
perspective you don't you can't have fun
like going to clubs and enjoy your life
and go and girls and drink with your
friends and eat whatever you want and
wake up when you want to and eat when
you want to and sleep when you want to
write people talk about freedom today
real freedom I can do whatever I want so
question will be why would someone
educate it including many many many many
women choose to complicate their life
and make it so difficult and cover with
hijab and be discriminated against and
have to pray five times a day and have
to observe all these rules and laws and
regulation unless unless there's
something there there's really really
something there and it would be one two
five ten fifteen you know you find
sometimes like you know some American
people went to India and converted to
Hinduism and they're doing vows of
silence somewhere in a temple that's
okay you know you hear that
but when you're talking about millions
of intellectuals of people who were
doing whatever they wanted to do in
their life no one could tell them what
to do no one could tell what time to
wake up what time to go to sleep what to
eat who to marry what to do they could
do what everyone an educator so when
those people commit to Islam then a
rational smart person whoever they be I
don't care where you're from what's your
background you need to ask yourself a
very simple question and be serious and
honest about it the question is why yeah
that's a lie that's a good point it's
it's it's very important and you're
talking about why would they why would
they give up sleeping in to wake up for
the early before dawn prayer why would
they give up alcohol going tonight cause
why would they and giving up things that
are actually things are that are mainly
destructive so and these things when you
implement them they're actually making
your life better and it's not like if
you make
contrast like when you had saw Paul of
Tarsus who was a going against for
instance many of the companions of Jesus
changing the laws and making things
easier meaning that he was about he was
like he was having telling people they
don't have to circumcise they don't have
to give up this debt and the other just
too watered it so that so much down that
now to make it easier for the people and
but they changed the whole the whole
thing he just like pretty much a made up
or less new religious the definition of
faith and he is that you have to have a
commitment to God it's not just lip
service the first and foremost thing you
have to do and you owe it to God if you
if you say you believe in God if you
don't then we have a different story
that we have to talk about and we have
to debate our different debate but if
you claim that you are looking for a
spiritual enlightenment and you claim
that you want to be with God then you
all got a commitment because it is so
clear to see that he has given you
everything it doesn't matter whether
yours in some difficulty in your life or
a financial constraint whatever still
just the fact that you can breathe and
see or hear or walk or sit or whatever
just that you have an extra breath in
this life that is a huge blessing and
you all got a huge commitment and
commitment means to really commit it's
not that you do whatever you do whenever
you do whenever you feel like it doesn't
make sense that God has created all this
and he said others I mean like has he
really created everything in play he
asked us he asked this interesting
rhetorical question do you think that
everything has been created in play and
you'll not be returned to us because
with all the respect and I don't you
know I respect people but at the same
time we have to analyze things if you
were to put any theology of any religion
on the table and analyze it you would
see that people kind of do whatever they
feel that they should do as opposed to
what God or revelation told him to do
and that's the funny thing that even
even
let's say the revelations are corrupt
which can be easily debate and argue
even then they will not follow it even
those revelations that they have with
them they fail to stick to them and
Allah insert a mine that calls them to
account saying that you have no ground
to stand upon at least do you hold firm
to what you think has been revealed to
you so even to that people cannot stand
you know what I mean because for example
the Bible says God is one and even to
that sadly Christians cannot hold on
yeah how would you yeah that's
interesting that Prophet Muhammad peace
and blessings be upon him I mean you
would think if he was an impostor he
would make it again easy on people and
he would say God go ahead and drink
alcohol I'll go ahead and fornicate no
no but he's putting morally upright
regulations that are coming from the
Creator things that you have to struggle
to implement but it's better for you so
you just when you think about that
unlike when I was making that example
with someone else just you know
destroying all the laws that came from
the Creator is there any before we get
back to that question about the veracity
of some of these people that are
attacking Islam and how this all came up
when I was talking to the Romanians I
was explaining to them the concept of
one and only one God how God sent
messengers and they agree they agree
they say yes just one God one God and
they're asking but what's the
manifestation of God then they start
going towards the Trinity what do you
like to say when people bring this up
yeah well that's the same argument that
the Hindus make right
what's the manifestation of God no I
mean this is what goes against the
concept of pure monotheism they claim
their monotheism but it's not pure
because as soon as you start saying but
as soon as you just add a butt in there
right it's like it doesn't work you
money yeah yeah we believe in one God
but what's the manifestation tell us
it's not it's not pure anymore because
God says he is one not one is unique not
just unique here is perfect so when you
analyze okay fine let's analyze these
manifestations
so okay you say God is all-knowing so
then Jesus came to the tree he did not
know that it does not bear fruit and he
also was asked about the day of judgment
he says no one knows of this except
okay same thing with the Hindus the
Hindus will debate all kinds of
different gods fighting amongst each
other being demigods semi gods I mean
that's what I'm saying put it on the
table and analyse it because God is
perfect and the perfection is the filter
that's what it must let's just look at
it I asked people just examining you
know just at least you owe it to
yourself to just give it a read just
read the Quran a bit if you cannot read
the whole thing just read parts of it
just do it you owe it to yourself you
owe it to God to at least look into it
you know if what if there's not go
finish your thought there's a difference
between an explanation and an evidence
people make a lot of explanations they
explain a lot I mean there's volumes
that will explain to you what the
Trinity is but that's not proof it does
not prove anything it's just people
philosophizing so there's a difference
between evidence and between explanation
yeah this was very clear when when I was
talking to our Romanian friends we were
giving evidence and then they would go
off and give excellent and give stories
and explanations you would you would
quote that Jesus said hear o Israel the
Lord thy God is one when he was asked
about the hour he said no one knows not
eat him so this like he goes back to god
almighty being all-knowing he can't be
ignorant or so him not knowing and then
they start giving explanation well
there's a hierarchy and there's God the
Father and the son but something's he
knows he does it but then you're
destroying the whole concept of Trinity
because you're scripted though you know
they think these things these are all
script they're all scripted things that
they learn and they have to explain so
when we say one leave it alone there's
no but after that unique leave one just
one and this resonates the human being I
mean when he hears this as someone's
mine you got to remove some of the
fitrah the natural state that the human
being was born and this connects with it
you know you just got to remove some of
these layers of the deception the lies
the fogginess something interesting here
whenever you ask a revert or convert
whatever you want to call it to Islam
why did they leave Christianity or any
other ones
okay what they would tell me what's the
one main reason they will usually say
it's because of the oneness of God
because the Trinity was not making sense
there's no evidence it's always the same
story you're talking about millions of
people even in some of the books after
ear of history well you have mention of
priests and you know rabbis and
different people you talking hundreds of
years ago being in Baghdad or in Syria
you have some of these books written by
scholars where people left Christianity
and became Muslims you will always find
the same trend that they were looking
for the pure monotheism however let's
flip it whenever you hear one of these
best time sellers who left Islam and
became Christian or whatever right and
they get all the interviews on on media
and oh my god you know they left Islam
he was an imam before he was studying
Shetty not sherry sherry you know they
make these funniest weirdest mistakes
and basic stuff for Islam which shows
you how experts the world right but
whenever you find their story as to why
they left Islam they'll say something
like oh used to strict the laws and
everything is about doing don't and
Prophet Mohammed he fought with people
and it's never about looking for the
true creator who has created them
there's be something about love and how
Jesus they saw Jesus in a dream by the
way shit-ton takes the shape of anyone
to dream except the prophets of I
sentence you know so it's an immediate
devil sorry Shaitaan the devil in every
way yeah yeah so you know I mean I've
analyzed and I discussed with probably
thousands of people by now in the past
16 years inside a Muslim like I'm
talking about day and day in and day out
and it's always kind of the same stories
you know that they're looking for love
yes or that no one says that they're
looking for that one true God that is in
this
is that their own scriptures are saying
that it's one yeah no one's gonna say
that oh yeah I was looking for the
Trinity for the try you and you know God
or something like that
it's just not there now you mentioned
something about reading the Quran
reading it open mind you've read all
these other books read the verbatim Word
of God Almighty and decide for yourself
but now is there any veracity we know
there isn't but for the person that is
was about to read the Quran and then
they heard of some let's say a
particular Muslim scholar that some of
these people were a nefarious agenda
nefarious agenda and evil intent they
are taking the read into a lot of the
things he said and some of the vague
statements there and what happens now is
they are taking this and putting it out
there and to create some confusion in
the mind so now there's some doubt
because they're saying that hold on
there's variations of the Quran how
would you respond to this the person now
is ready but now this has them
second-guessing themselves of course
this is very clear I think most of the
Muslims know it's kind of going on right
now in the social media and this is
nothing new actually it's been going on
for some time I was actually part of
that group that specific restricted
group that this this teacher talks about
in his interview okay I was parted I saw
him you're talking about six seven years
ago these discussions were going on on
that group okay wait wait so help us
understand like what do you mean group
and discussions were exactly what I'm
talking about
first of all we have to understand a few
things just I don't want to lengthen it
too much but I think there's important
for people to understand a little bit of
context okay because a lot of people are
making a mistake and attacking the
brother in a very unpolite way which
will not get through a lot of people are
insulting and they think they have the
right to do so and that is not correct
it doesn't work like that not just
because they don't he doesn't deserve it
or anything that but this is not the
necessarily the best way to approach
someone it's not gonna go through as you
can see he has frustrated and from these
people and it's not gonna explain
anything this person is a very learned
person is a very smart person I know him
personally I'm not sure if we can
mention his name or not we can I mean
everyone knows what we don't have to I
mean if you don't worry we don't have to
or it's up to you yeah I mean people
know we're talking about but out of
respect you know it's assumed that the
process was to not mention names that
but everyone knows who we're talking
about so I mean I'm not his best friend
but I know him personally and you know
he is a good man I'm a lost man I only
protect him I mean but yeah but everyone
is to understand that everyone cares the
responsibility when it comes and there's
background to that but again the people
need to really chill out when they talk
because he is gaining points by being a
victim by people attacking him and you
know kind of insulting it which is not
correct it should be a proper discussion
or people can put out their reputations
the problem is so this group was a email
group that was created by some students
at knowledge and he mentions it in his
heed in his interviews previous interest
so I'm not saying something you know
that's that's restricted or I think that
he himself mentioning explained what it
was so I was part of that group and I
would see his basic group of student of
knowledge then discuss different Islamic
things they will not necessarily get in
public and then obviously some brothers
took that because it was quite alarming
what he was saying on that group and
what he was presenting there so some
people took it from there and put it as
public and then people start making all
kinds of things I think a lot of things
were not set properly a lot of context
and it became bigger than it was
supposed to be right so and this email
group basically some of the things that
were discussed whether the Yahoo for the
Toronto an are basically variations of
the Quran or what are they and so on and
so forth which he mentions in the
interview as well it's funny to say that
well these are private and it shouldn't
be discussed in public but then they are
discussed in public I mean obviously
they kind of leaked
but it sounds so weird right side kind
like a wiki leak you know and it's
leaked out and with the Muslims are
tryna hide some it's so bad because and
again it you know it takes a few people
to to make a problem right so when these
brothers leak these documents or these
emails you made a bigger problem because
it sounds like oh my god you know these
students of knowledge are hiding the
truth it's like you know people will
accuse the Catholic Church from that
they're hiding the real Bible there's no
just just for the record just a
disclaimer there is no such thing as
takea in Islam is that correct I mean I
have I've resources I've talked to
different scholars and what I've come to
see that this is a certain sect outside
of a certain particular sect that uses
this but in in the Orthodox tradition of
the following the Prophet Muhammad
there's no such thing as takea this word
takea okay so maybe in the word but the
concept is there but not the way they
see it the concept as in less if someone
asks you are you Muslim they're putting
a gun to your head you can see I'm not
and that's the key yeah yeah
sealing it if you're if you're hiding if
you're hiding let's say the the Jews
from the from like the Muslims we're
saving the Jews at one time and the
Nazis were coming down to to kill them
and you saving the Jewish people and now
you're saying no they're not in the
basement this is an exception yeah it's
kind of like a lie to protect someone's
life or to hide or your wife or your
wife what about your wife cook some food
and you don't want to get in trouble so
howhow is it she puts a too much salt
yeah but is she asking like the most
beautiful woman so this is beautiful you
have these exceptions but to delivery
try to try to something that to hide the
truth to twist things to try to get
people into Islam this is this is a this
is a big thing that a las pathetic calls
in the Quran that Eve specifically when
you distort the Quran or the book or the
message of the Quran and of course
hiding it as well that's another big
surprise we have turkey for changing the
book on changing the message of Islam in
general not just the Quran and then
hiding it yeah okay that is another see
it's a compound okay I'll tell you a
true story sorry don't lose your place
that I was one of my teachers we were
there in the beginning years and there
was a Muslim who just started practicing
Islam and he said as a Christian was
going to come in they're gonna have a
dialogue and the Muslim said hey I'm
gonna pretend like I was Christian too
and I accepted Islam and the Muslim
scholar said no we don't do that we
don't deceive like that that's right
that's right that is very very correct
it's not allowed it's a big shame yeah
sorry go ahead and finish what you were
saying yes so this we're talking about
this group right so this group there's
some discussion specifically about the
theory you know the the the accrual for
the Quran of the para for those who do
not know what these are these are okay
recitations of the Quran
people use the word variant okay this is
incorrect okay this is incorrect and
it's not very ok these are okay modality
is a recitation that will reveal to the
process element because people don't
know what they are and of course when
you hear their word you're like oh my
god is this and that's when I first
learned about then I was like oh my god
what is this that's because people don't
have knowledge in general if you go to
the Iranian world who understands
language the Arabic language well and
you talk to them about what is a Quran
and so on in general people will know
okay in general people they studied they
will know it it's usually in the West or
they're not so knowledgeable in Arabic
that I do not understand the concept of
this issue but going back to the to the
subject so there is no variation or
different or aunts and sadly of course
because of this this brother has you
know released this interview and now
people are wondering what is saying of
course the the missionaries were just
waiting for something like that because
he has a certain search a position the
community is eligible he is respected so
they're taking this kind of statements
on saying see see you see it's just why
you guys attacking us on the on the
court on the Bible it's just like the
see you guys have all these different
readings so there's a few problems that
number one is you cannot compare the two
whatsoever from any angle possible okay
that's not nothing like that from
preservation from history from anything
any angle these two the Quran in the
Bible cannot be compared I'm so sorry I
know a lot of Muslims use the Bible to
do that and so on and it's okay we can
look at the concepts that what they
talks about and show the people that hey
look man even you guys don't even
believe what your book is saying that's
fine but there's no comparison in terms
of variation or in terms of preservation
or in terms of the validity of the book
historically or whatever you might have
it right so that's that's something that
needs to be clarified the Quran has been
revealed in the Arabic language in the
first place until today it is in the
Arabic language okay no one had to the
translation of the Quran are not or
hands in and so they're just meaning or
interpretations of the meanings and
every schoolchild will know that right
every single person knows that so people
are just a bit confused as to what the
statements that the brother said and
sadly again it will bring doubt amongst
people and of course the enemies of
Islam are just waiting to jump on that
and to Kindle the fire of doubt and
sadly because a lot of people don't have
the knowledge of the Quran I mean it
let's be honest
a lot of people don't really care about
studying Islam and I'm not talking about
memorizing a few surah so you can pray
that's that's not you know that's not
the way it is you know that's that's
never meant to be like that not for
stuff that's what happened to previous
nations that people left the faith so
only a few people I in there scholars
were able to hide behind closed doors
and decide what is the revelation
Council of Nicaea Council of Trent and
many on the council's because people
were I mean people are not even allowed
to read the Bible you could be executed
if you were found in the position of a
Bible reading a Bible and this is you
know fact you got to look into history
so this has never been the case for a
Muslim even the compilation of the Quran
was the public endeavor
it was done in public on the stairs of
the message of the profits of my asylum
you know what I mean
everyone knew exactly what is going on
and by the window Lauren was already
with the people in their memory but
people wanted to see that there's
nothing going on right I mean there's
nothing like there's no such thing the
Quran can never be corrupted in the
first place because of the way it's been
revealed because of its memorization it
can never and that's the interesting
thing is that you can actually test that
you can actually test that and that's
why recently I was reading to one of the
stories that I was telling about one of
the believers and basically this this
man was asked to convert his time he was
a a non Muslim and it was in the time
when the Calathes
and the men's he denied he said what I
wanted then he went back and he said the
same person who asked him I saw him a
year later giving a lecture on Islam and
he said what happened and he said well I
went back home and I took some Bibles in
some poor hands and some you know other
books and I changed them and I started
selling them right and customers came
back being upset well guess which
customers working when the Christians
the Jews no they're not that was the
Muslims who came back saying that the
Quran has been change this is not the
real Quran what are you doing angry give
me my money back you should fear God
okay you know so he said I tested it you
know because God will preserve his
message missing you know very simple
till today that can be tested no you
cannot change if you were to a be able
to change it a thousand years ago you
can change it today you know right but
it cannot be changed is there any any so
there's no veracity to many of these
arguments they're making is there
anything that you came across from from
what had happened recently some things
that they have said that had you at one
point when you're studying when you're
studying some of the this particular
area that had you scratching your head
that had you second-guessing
had you doubt or is there something that
you seeing that okay if I just get this
piece of the pose I put it together it
answers the question clears the doubt
anything like this okay so first of all
the people to get a proper understanding
of what's going on I think they can go
back to the ICR double a.org
and read the article that i wrote a few
years ago on this specific topic of the
seminar oath or the carrot and what do
they mean what is the terminology mean
and in this article actually analyzed
the book of this brother and you know
kind of just summarized because I read
this book a few times and any book
that's available in the subject in the
English language anyway and done
research of course in the Arabic
language so but specifically I analyzed
you know what is available out there in
English so with regards to was there any
doubt in me when I first heard about
these things specifically you know he
even mentions in this there's one Sahaba
that kind of the same thing when he
first heard about the doubt enter his
heart and process and hit his heart and
you know doubt left his heart because if
you don't understand not understanding
something will cause you to doubt no no
issues what now do we sensation eyes
this instant oh my god you know it
became he was in doubt you have to
understand that there was people who
left Islam during the time of the
process elephants for when there was a
literal Niraj when the night dissension
took place the process and went from
Mecca to Jerusalem and up to meet a loss
mentality when he came back many people
or companions at the time they cannot
become uncompetitive did not dawned on
the deed but they left Islam and because
they couldn't believe that this can
happen they were used to traveling to
sham and to Yemen in the winter and
summer and they said we cannot accept
them right so doubt is part of human
beings we cannot make it sensationalize
oh my god this companion headed up of
course everyone will have them down you
know I mean here now but the other ones
didn't seem tell how far how far we
reading into that I mean that should
tell us right
err I mean that dot was cleared so that
gives us an example I mean look at the
transparency here there's nothing hidden
and and it is a different how much you
reading into that word what's the actual
word in the Arabic language you know
what what what you know you how much are
you giving emphasis doubt like what is
it what does that mean to you and to him
it's just is it he's like okay he just
needed a little more clarification like
I look at Abraham peace be upon him when
he wanted to he wanted you know he's
asking God Allah how does he bring them
that yeah life I mean what is he
shouting seulbi's my heart finds so can
we use that it's same thing with this
companion so ok listen I want some some
say a little bit more that happens to
all of us there's something that you
just someone will come up you don't have
the proper knowledge then then you're
wait I've had this happen so many times
where you'll see something someone will
bring up because many of these people
they study I mean they've they've gone
into the universities it's so sad with
this nefarious agenda you know about
this and to go ahead and study Islam I
try to try to destroy the amount of the
Muslims but when I patient and then
Allah can also be testing you now let's
see you're gonna bat JumpShip but then
someone will bring another hadith will
bring the answer and it's like
alhamdulillah it's there yeah as I said
the companion Jesus the same thing they
asked him to send out the mind or the
table right Moussa wanted to see God
okay same thing and you know so it
happened over and over again this is I
mean these are talking you talking about
prophets here right so we should have
sensationalized one incident and say oh
my god you know look he had a doubt of
course it's not like that because you
will get people to be confused yeah
understand when you speak you are
responsible for those people you cannot
just take the responsibility away and
say well you know I've gone through some
phases and I can't study in this
university and I've you know seen so
many different issues and I've gone
through phases and you know somehow you
feel that people are gonna feel bad for
you and all of a sudden they're gonna
listen to you no it's not like that
there's a huge responsibility and to be
honest when I first took this brother
course in 2000 and this was 2005 I think
right I mean and then I read the book
and everything so I mean even in the
book he fails to clarify this issue and
this is long time ago then I took the
second course at University of Toronto
and again people were confused after the
class and they complained to the Dean of
the studies at that time which was
another brother I'm not gonna Institute
and I'm not gonna name the brothers
again you start respect but because
there was no clarity given on the
subject while the clarity exists you
know you have to go back to the simplest
things first to be you know because yeah
if you look through the book and in the
interview he will say something I would
even adjust that he says this that he
spent so many years trying to understand
what is this word mean well that that's
not for the Muslims a binding evidence
people need to understand it with all
due respect to every single scholar as
one of our great Imam says that I can
take or reject the opinions of people
Allah accepts I who have the color that
person was in this grave and he pointed
towards away from the prophets Allah
Allah
right so you cannot use the okay great
scholar of Islam great scholar on the
subject yes but even him you know even
taymiyah for example Himalayas to say
that sometimes I used to think of a
certain you know think for days and you
know as to make toe but it's the far and
the al-aswad the opens my mind to
understand you know just we cannot use
the appeal which is the fallacy the
appeal to Authority to try to justify a
mistake or a doubt or in fact that just
because a certain scholars in a certain
position instill he's not infallible
okay just because he spent 20 years or
so on what you're talking about hundreds
of years ago when you know we didn't
have encyclopedias you know on a
research you know window you can just
research things right
today you have you know Maxima Shambhala
or any of these other night
that are searched on the internet
scholars and access to bring all the
hadith together you can do an exhaustive
research I'm not saying that they're
better than this one or that but I'm
just trying to put things in perspective
you cannot use that incident to show
that well you know he had he didn't know
what it means so here you know here we
are guys we don't you know that's let's
try to look at different understandings
and different you know issues and I
think that is very erroneous that's very
problematic for someone to to make these
kind of statements because it will and
and then failing to explain it you
haven't left it explained so you make
this kind of talk oh yeah there is a
group we're debating this we're talking
about that if you just that he said this
this scholar said that this Sahaba had a
doubt okay guys see you later son
Michael it shouldn't be talked in public
about it and then you know no you have
to come on I think you have to whoever
did this has to come out and clear the
doubts has to come out because when
people listen to you as they would come
to the Prophet SAW some and we know the
companion who was leaving the Prophet
SAW so his presence and he saw was the
Abu Bakr Siddiq and he said you know
when I feel like a hypocrite right he
said when I'm with the Prophet SAW some
I'm like I'm on cloud you know nine he's
at the highest level imam when i leave
him so if you're an Islamic scholar your
physical physician man people when they
leave you you are the one who's helping
helping right to facilitate nurturing of
the knowledge and people's Imam growing
people cannot leave an Islamic scholar
and the Iman goes down you can leave him
without right so you right that makes
sense of course especially when people
follow you a lot you know I mean there's
got to be a man booster to clarify
things and of course you're not you
don't you're not hiding something or not
but see the problem is that even when
you read through his books through his
book sometimes his book is a compilation
of the different opinions on the subject
which is great okay fine but you need to
also bring out the spirit and clarify
the issue you know what I mean if you
make certain statements you make certain
you know allegations that you have to
clarify
the states but you cannot leave things
unaddressed and again in the shock
effect that's the problem with most of
you know these kind of statements look
there was as I told you there was a
Hamas or not service for people are in
the round process and we left this time
there's an incident where one of the
guys used to say I was a scribe for the
process of self I was a scribe and the
Orientalists and the non-muslims used
this hadith a lot but I want you to pay
attention just so you understand that
it's not just about saying something oh
look what this habit did or look with
that and then ignoring the whole context
so usually when I respond to to
Christians or interest when they bring
out this thing they'll say well there is
this Sahaba who wrote the revelation and
then he says that he himself said that
well you know the promise was that we
should dictate to me a certain work I
would change the words what a fool Rahim
I'll say about him over food and this
and that
Mohammed doesn't know anything from the
Quran except what I wrote down know so
it's actually it's written okay so
people say see look at that
ah but read the hadith the guy died and
they tried to bury him and the earth
were not accepted till the end they had
to just put some rocks on top of his
body and leave him above the earth Wow
because I'm cursed him but you see you
ignored that part you just want to focus
on you know do you think just this is an
example this is an example I was looking
for so this is where they they studied a
Dean study Islam with that nefarious
evil intent and they take half out of
context not give you like you just did
you can just take that and full stop
there and you'll be like wow man they
got evidence here look but then when you
go the rest of the way this person it's
known this is the news reports at that
time the media is reporting that the
earth wouldn't take would spit this
person out yes exactly I mean and people
need to look at I mean that's a miracle
first of all it got cursing and Allah
when you look at it see if you know the
Quran and you understand the Quran the
Quran cannot be changed and it's gone
through so many checking stages and okay
let's say this ayah
change some things even today if I want
to I can take a pen and I can start
writing from the Quran and change words
does that mean that the Quran has
changed some years ago this whole thing
started when they found a part of the
Quran in Yemen and then they released
the whole article they all see these are
variant Quran x' and you know I'm strong
as the Orientalist jumped on that and
others you know jumped on it and if you
look at it's like come on guys this is
like Islam 101 you know what I mean in
the Prophet SAW Selim angel jibreel
revealed recited the Quran and revised
the Quran with him the Sahaba would pray
behind the prophet sallallaahu salad you
know they would hear every single ayah
and surah and these crimes were there
and who found were there it's not just
like people think that it's just the
Quran was written and then there's some
doubts and some scribes and some things
and all of a sudden here we are
different variations of the Quran and I
really don't like the word they use the
word variants you know and sadly our
brothers who are ulema or scholars of
Islam will start using some of this
terminology which even this brother is
using you know medieval neos this you
know that it's it's not I would say
correct it can confuse people you know
using these non-muslim terms you know in
terminology but what do you say when
someone says no these are just academic
terms in academia that are used yeah but
whose academia you know and that's I
think a lot of people also need to
understand the concept and the context
behind that when I am from seven years
seven years now I cannot remember
exactly a time I don't want to say the
exact time but some time ago when this
brother entered this famous university I
met with with his boss pretty much and
we had lunch in Dubai and he was worried
and he said look this guy has a Jewish
and they ate his teacher teaching him
Islam and he said I'm concerned and this
is one of his best friends you know I
talked about his boss all right
and he said I'm really concerned about
him because they're teaching him kufan
now please be careful I'm not saying
that stuff for Allah not even the
smallest thing that he you know he's
anything but this brother was concerned
you say he's been taught cook for by
these people
another very close teacher of mine and
friend he enrolled in one of these
universities and he called me and he
said I'm leaving gibreel I said why I
share he said it is I'm giving myself
the fatwa it is impermissible for me to
study in this university he says it is
haram for me to listen to what these
people have to say why are you afraid of
the truth or something like now see
people need to analyze the love the
whole situation 360 degrees it's not
about being afraid and through a brother
it's about that even the statements that
he makes even the claims that his
brother makes there are only opinions
and he has learned opinions of different
people different theories that are based
on certain philosophical aspects that
have changed the fundamentals in his
faith which of which is an expert in
Aikido right so when you look at this
this is based on opinions so his opinion
a lot of people forget guys that in the
end you can study Sharia you can study
Koran you can study everything but you
forget one thing before even Allah has
revealed any revelation it is the fitrah
of a human being you are a human being
that can be influenced you are a human
being that if you go in the wrong
environment nurturing would take over
the environment would dictate to your
don't scholars love to quote the example
Imam Shafi and others who have gone to
Egypt and they have changed their Fatah
was based on the Empire
and based on the new things that they
have met right depending on the culture
and so on that's exactly what it is your
environment will dictate the way you
start thinking the way you start talking
and even the way you look at things the
the specs that you'll be wearing will be
influenced by who you are hearing from
who you are listening from who you are
learning from and no one is infallible
anyone can be influenced by this and
that is why you can find and easily
trace a change in the behavior and the
discourse when he was in Saudi Arabia
that this course was totally different
he calls it a change in transition and
growing and maturing that's fine that's
those are just slogans that does not
remember there's evidence and there's
explanations that's not evidence for
anything that's just an explanation
because when it was in Saudi Arabia the
discourse was totally different why even
we might not agree with that by the way
we might not even agree with that type
by the way but that influence was there
he was in that environment and hence he
was giving lectures based on what he has
learned there and the culture and the
man hatch or the way of that place isn't
it and till today you can find those
lectures then the shifts happen and you
start seeing a change in the lectures
that are coming in and then another
shift and another shift and another
shift and then there you are in a
different environment and you will be
influenced there's no it's also its
basic human psychology yeah you match a
couple things you mentioned the words so
in academia where certain words are used
and then not having do we have to always
go with those terms for instance in
academia can be used certain words like
Islamist jihadist I interviewed one care
representative director he refused to
even repeat these words he says these
words are systematically set up that
they are out there to create confusion
to attack Islam he doesn't want to say
jihadis you don't say Islam is because
these are just words made up and we know
they have negative connotations
so is this an example with some of
these words that are used that we don't
have to repeat these words if they're
used in that DeRogatis they have
derogatory connotation as many times and
just like for example if somebody
somebody for instance just make an
example for instance people know this
group's know this for instance if you
take the word sodomite or sodomy for
instance which is technically by
definition this is what certain act is
this certain people do but people know
this is textbook but now the term has
been changed now to give it a nice
flavor and whatnot yeah I mean I wish we
would have hours to discuss this issue
because there's there's so much can we
make that example is do these things
connect now do we see a play of words it
doesn't even a lost mantle I'll talk
about this how they change Rosa yeah no
doubt and see the thing is I mean
african-americans in the United States
they have reclaimed the you know a
certain word right that even me and you
cannot say I should not see right
because you can get but they say it
amongst themselves right it's not the
same thing but you can understand what
the importance of words you know is
words are very very important the same
way that you said that this scholar was
not accepting you know Islam or Islamic
you have this and all that me being for
example in the field of education I was
trying to propose a research on
education on moving away from terms that
are invented by by the West and we were
calling it the D westernization of
educational terminology like why because
C words claim and carry a huge meaning
and not just that they belong to a
certain you know category in a certain
culture and when you start using these
words like for example I know Muslims
don't but so today the word is in use
Muhammed ism or Muhammad dis okay this
is what the I don't buy it because the
Orientalist of all they studied Islam
they knew Arabic they snuck into the
Kaaba and to see Hajj and Umrah and they
learned and they knew the culture the
herbs they knew exactly what Islam is
but these terms are usually
made up and put together to distort
meaning and to confuse people
right so you find it in the books of
Orientalism the term muhammed is of
muhammad ism to define or to say islam
because it has a connotation it kind of
means that we have you know what kind of
worshipping or everything is about
muhammad yeah which is not in Islam it's
all about submission they want to make
it as equal to Christ Christianity
Buddhist Buddhism or Buddha Buddhism
Taoism Tao Confucianism confuses you
know they want associate it you just put
in the same plate and that's what's
happening right now with the these
so-called variant readings or different
readings of the Quran and so they want
to put in exactly the same plate to see
on see you guys have the same thing why
you guys talking about the Bible because
one of the main objectives or us or
objection of any believer when it comes
to the Bible it's that it's being
corrupted you cannot accept it you
cannot you ask them the Christian man
like can't you guys see can't you guys
read that the beginning of the chapter
of Luke for example when he says that he
appeared to him that it was good that he
should also write the things they were
you not told can you not see that this
is not revelation this is a human you
know intervention this is people doing
it right so they want to put the Quran
in the same type of plate and of course
sadly sometimes people don't understand
that you know there's so many people
watching you listening to interviews and
you're saying things and you think well
I'm an academician I'm an academics I
can use this term or say this and that
I'm not hiding anything but you don't
understand that you will cause confusion
and then people you know it takes very
easy brother take any building you
dynamite it you can finish it off in a
few minutes but building it will take a
long time brother and that's why it
takes one person to say Muhammad peace
be upon it was a pedophile okay just a
one statement and you'll take me maybe
twenty pages to convince someone or
thirty which requires sometimes two
weeks of work of research to try to
convince
someone that this is not the case hmm
right it's so it's so easy to break
something and to confuse someone and to
cause a doubt it will be so difficult to
pass that up
and to explain no it's not like that to
remove it education as much ease is much
more difficult than breaking someone's
you know knowledge it's very very yeah a
couple more things I just want to cover
before we conclude tell me you made a
good point about being in certain
environments and can you make the
contrast with because we can understand
if you put yourself for instance where
many people will go on the weekends to
the club let's say for instance you go
to the club and you can understand with
the music and all the temptations in
there no one would argue that ok this is
a place I shouldn't be because I will be
affected even though you have so
interesting some people if they say I'll
go to the club I won't drink or anything
and I'll try to get people Dowell in the
club you've heard this before
of course ok so here's the example we
can understand this is ludicrous this is
crazy you know you're putting your Dean
and in jeopardy
a place where fornication where drugs
were all that this that environment
imagine that environment will have
effect on your your your heart and your
soul can you make a similar example if
now the mind also connected with the
heart when you're in some of these in
some of these classrooms from some of
these professors that are out there who
they're now goal is to many of these
institutions these secular institutions
they're out there also giving their Dawa
and they're trying to destroy your iman
like when you go on some of these places
and they're making fun of Jesus peace be
upon them they're making fun of religion
and whatnot can we make the contrast
there that this also will can affect you
the same way you're in the club and you
sin but this can affect you maybe in a
possible worst way because you end up
here you commit a sin and what now here
you can end up losing your Deen and we
see this happening like you'll see this
you've seen this documentary called
expelled no intelligence is allowed have
you seen that exactly I've seen it no no
that's quite an old doctrine you
understand the contract the example I'm
giving here I understand one-armed
percent can we connect the two like that
no doubt no doubt because see
I think this brother is not an I mean he
reads a lot is smart and everything but
his his expertise eNOS is in a certain
field and that is a key that and the
problem is that he's made this move and
I've talked to a lot of scholars who
have the same type of plan they go for
example study in Medina or in Saudi
Arabia they do their bachelor's and
master's then they say well I want to go
back to the west and get a PhD so I get
the both best of both worlds you know
and in reality brothers it's a big
mistake till today
so today I tell people in the in the
East to to be careful with their
decisions when it comes to specifically
education specifically education people
like you and I ID we know we're coming
from a geliar we are coming from so in a
scarlet this is a good point you're
mentioning because let's say a scholar
from over there says no go do that he
don't know what's going on over here no
no he doesn't understand people just go
to college for the experience you know
holla so a lot of people don't
understand and he himself this brother
is not a specialist in understanding the
human psychology and the mind and so how
the funny thing is that he admits that
he's gone through a crisis and sadly I
don't know if he realizes that he gains
the sympathy of people and that is a
very strong card in an argument because
if you notice the way has been going on
a line right now a lot of people are
defending blindly this issue and
defending him because they're of course
infatuated with him his Dalton a
reputation and he's using this you know
he's been attacked and insulted he's
also talking about a crisis in life that
he's gone through which a lot of people
can identify with you know what I mean
is this person's gone to the he's not
has come to the west but he's the
Westerner and here's he's trying to
figure out the things that people cannot
understand he himself admits that he's
gone through that crisis but see that
itself indicates you're talking about
going through a crisis and someone who's
having doubts and rethinking his whole
five is very problematic for someone to
follow that and to take from from this
person with all due respect not just
that not just that but he himself I had
lunch with him just before the lockdown
it was you're talking about maybe two
and a half months ago okay here in
Malaysia and when dr zakir as well and i
asked him the question i said what's
going on
why are you kind of in in a polite way
what's happening and he said you bleed
you don't understand what we're going
through in the West okay this there's a
lot of pressure on us and he says it's
publicly that people are leaving Islam
and we have to protect them but
automatically I said in analytical Bala
mining and he said it's not your job to
keep people in Islam man you're supposed
to just convey the message with all due
respect you know what I mean and that's
the problem you know a lot of people are
trying to do the job of a loss of talent
it's not your job to find explanations
that somehow would convince the people
to stay in Islam because you're not the
wine the Cal attacked him and I've done
what I can on my acne measure you can do
not guide whom you love Allah guides
whom He wills
your job as a Muslim scholar teacher is
only to convey the message it sounds
harsh if people want to leave Islam
guess what you're not gonna be able to
stop them the prophets lesson could not
could not convince his own beloved uncle
to become Muslim so you think you will
keep people in his lap and he says that
he says it openly that so many people in
Islam were faced with so many doubts and
challenges by the youth and we have to
protect we have to give them
explanations that make sense and this is
that you're basically violating the
principles of your own study which is
al-qaeda which is belief in many of the
unseen of things that you know
rationally you can it's not that you
cannot explain it or they're irrational
is that it's difficult to achieve a full
understanding or food you know evidence
of this you cannot see God but you can
see the
and the power of God in the creation and
so many things you're not having I mean
people don't see the Kobe virus for
God's sake not I mean but you know they
see what you know be it or do where it
is or not they see what the mess is
created economically and everyone just
wearing a mask for God's sake right now
you know why not sign looking you know
with with a mask and be sanitizing their
hands and being so it's a part of life
just it kills me but going back to the
argument is that it's not your business
to guide people to protect people and I
think he's gone beyond the limits
because he's not I mean you know I with
all due respect I call a lot of these
brothers even if they are demands may
Allah bless them protect them I pray for
them I understand that it is a very
difficult time I know what they've gone
through because I've also been there but
Allah so canta Indian says was was my
earth not wide enough for you to make
you know move make a job go some of us
if you cannot stand it you cannot stand
it if you cannot if you can stand it
good okay maybe you need to be there but
if you cannot and you cannot carry the
responsibility and maybe you shouldn't
and with all due respect because a lot
of these brothers the same way that they
would say about someone else was not
qualified during the same you know level
as them I called him I kind of like
visitor you know type of or or you know
just sightseers because they don't work
with the people that closed even though
they do seminars they do lessons they
are in the message it but for example an
educator a teacher a principal who is
day in and day out with the youth okay
day in and day out knowing their
problems on my desk right now brother is
a case of a raped Muslim boy by by his
father on the case on my table right now
brother is the case of two lesbian girls
who are trying to you're saying that
they want to get married and adopt these
are Muslim okay they're not not Muslim
on the kid right now is a drug addict
you know Muslim I mean you don't hear
their people go to them don't go for
advice but it's not day in and day out
to see what is really happening and what
these peep
and that's another mistake they think
that in the West is some different world
brother brother Eddie we have sometimes
worse problems in the Muslim countries
and I lived in the Middle East for ten
years I live now in Malaysia now in a
year and a half and I didn't just leave
going to hotels and doing lectures and
having seminars I'm talking about living
and breathing with these people dealing
with their children learning their
languages and trust me brother this is a
global village right now there's no such
thing in the East and the West that in
the West we have this pressure and these
problems and we have to keep people in
Islam brother I have on my table right
now two apostates Muslims okay and one
of them who left because he's homosexual
I have all these things in the Muslim
countries right now okay look just in
Kuala Lumpur 400,000 youth are diagnosed
with mental health issues
five thousand babies are left on the
back streets because of zina just you
know delivered and aborted on the on the
street you're talking about a Muslim
country brother don't give me this West
has its you know major problems or he
says Oh in the East you guys are so
lucky you have any so easy Muslim
country you have no clue we're under
more attack actually in the Muslim
countries today be it intellectually be
it culturally be it you know from every
single point of view bottom line is it's
not up to us
who's guided who is not guided it's up
to us to deliver Islam to them as it is
this is our responsibility to teach
people
Allah Allah call our soul to explain to
them to give the correct things not to
find excuses to come up with with all
the respect bro you know I mean the last
issue of gog and magog ya'juj and ma'juj
you know what i mean i mean literally it
says like he said i can't believe this i
cannot accept that there's somewhere
behind the wall for four thousand years
and my my immediate question is why why
when you know that this is your field of
study to believe in the unseen to video
you'll say no it's not from the unseen
yeah lots of panel tan is put in such a
way or in such a position that it will
come towards the towards that they have
just just be cold because there's
telescopes and there's satellites and
Lily and I have the recording can
everyone can go and see the expression
as I cannot believe it doesn't make
sense but you can't believe if you want
to but I cannot believe you can't
believe she won't turn ugly you know
there's a habit of the Prophet SAW Selim
when the Sahaba the process I'm saying
about a cow they was talking a cow yes a
cop and the Sahaba said yeah allah but
Aranea cow it's this talking he said yes
a cow and i believe in it and a bucket
believes in it and all i believe in it
you know
look at this response you didn't say
well you know it's like this kind of
talk yeah maybe it's not talk man who's
figurative maybe it's just like in their
own language make he says i believe in
it and abu-bakr believes in it and all
not believe in it i mean we we we we
have we have how about the tree talking
during the time weeping during in
tennessee so we come but if you want can
welcome but but if you come if you come
now today they have you can check this
up there's confirmation that tree speak
between each other
I was talking to Hamza sources about
this it's about those trees now they
didn't hear it but I like for them to
hear you talked about true so amazing we
often hear the moisture problem Hamid
peace and blessing upon him about know
about the trees the book is called the
hidden life of trees it was a it was an
international bestseller and it's called
what they feel how they communicate
discoveries from a secret world right
and he brought this up some academic
studies that they've had between trees
so if you mentioned a tree talking and
now imagine that a tree trees
communicate with each other let me
before we conclude tell me what is your
response to this in the Western academia
we're dissecting and taking everything
you made a good example about you know
it just takes a a minute to just blow up
you know to destroy a building and it
takes so long to put it to
we know that the Quran verbatim word of
God Almighty Allah law says that I have
I will preserve this Quran that he's the
one that's protecting it he's going to
protect it it's preserved we have it
it's a living miracle so it's it's
producing great human beings who live by
it not just as preserved but people who
implement it it's a whole blueprint for
life except I said it now now the meat
and potatoes of it how we got it it's
there but how much dissection do we need
to go where you dismantle everything
like they do they just they dismantle
everything every nut and bolt and this
and that and everything and now for the
layman to try to like put together a car
I'm not talking about Ikea item just put
it together but just that I sucked a
huge piece of machinery and what not of
course is gonna be some confusion doubt
like how do I put this back together how
far do we go the layman has to go to
have to and especially maybe in academia
where they'd this date where they talk
about they had they destroy everything
for you and they say go I show us how to
put it together and if you can't put it
together it must not be the truth you
get the example yeah okay so first of
all because we're running out of time I
would and specific if you notice I
didn't want to go into detail to respond
to this issue of growth in karate or the
so called variances and so on and I
again I direct the people to read the
article on I see are double a.org
yeah plus there's articles there about
the preservation in history the Quran
because there's so much if I'm just
gonna tell you right now and talk to you
it's it might go over your head I want
it to go for certain principles and
mistakes that have been made with
respect elana respect and and I pray
that people understand the truth I
understand the difficulty that they're
going on as weak with regards to the
nuts and bolts okay people are at
different levels you have to understand
just because something says this and
says that you need to have full context
of things even if you read his book with
all due respect ok put his book verses
the book of most attack Yasmani for
example which talks on the same subject
and you feel two different things
because he didn't cover everything most
attacked with money is explained
because he is living in a place okay in
the subcontinent where the Muslims were
being attacked from the time of
colonization
the British were sending their you know
Sir William Muir and all the other
oriental is learning Arabic and
attacking the Muslims in their faith so
when most attackers monk is explaining
the issue Ventura is a whole different
story so there's so many details - for
you to be able to understand this is a
huge thing but it's very simple actually
right why is there so much detail so
many nuts and bolts because people have
written so much about it so actually
you're read reading the opinions of
people a lot of these nuts and bolts in
the end will be opinions of people go
back to revelation the Prophet SAW
seldom is sitting on the outskirts of
Medina and the angel comes to and says
ya Muhammad recite the Quran in one way
and he saw Allah I am says it will be
difficult for my people I'm sent to
people some literate some illiterate
some alter it will be difficult for them
to do that
do it in two ways it will be difficult
three four then the angel says recited
in seven ways whichever way recited it
is the truth wow this is amazing
. . okay . why what does it mean does it
mean variant doesn't mean this doesn't
mean Maliki and Maliki which is king and
sovereign earth in the different
readings is it a half Sun awesome or is
it wash or what bro it's like you're
talking about you know it's you know a
heart bypass or surgical this or a brain
you know surgery you need to have some
knowledge of that very simple the angel
said whichever way you recited it is
correct this is a this is a mercy I mean
if you look this is a miracle upon
miracle just when you think about it
this is like a mercy from the trader
that have is an earth and the most
interesting thing is brother is that if
you look at it okay
the Quran the Quran and the act roof are
not a doubt as sadly this brother tries
to
somehow allude to it or actually their
miracle because for a very simple reason
with all let's say let's say let's say
simple just for the sake of are you okay
don't take anyone might have to be
careful these days right don't take my
statement out of context just for the
sake of argument
okay there's Korat and their variant and
isn't that okay fine
even so there is not one contradiction
in the poor and among these karate or
monkeys you know and this is what one of
the Orientalists
says then when analyzing all these
planes still the theology of Islam is
intact now pay attention
let's parallel that to the variances in
the Bible and we know there's about 360
different verses the Bible okay more now
why are there when you're looking at the
different variant readings of the Bible
you'll find for example one book has
begotten the word begotten in John 3:16
one has unique one has if one doesn't
have that okay in Matthew the same thing
and look there's variants which
basically change what so for example the
first for there are three that bear
witness in heaven the Father the Son and
the Holy Ghost and the three are in
agreement this is an interpolator word
you'll find it in some variants and not
in others okay this is the objective of
variance is to change the actual faith
and that's why they've been done because
they're done by people when you look at
the Quran you'll never find anything to
threaten the al-qaeda or the faith of
Islam even if someone for the sake
marking to say oh you guys have seven
variants of the Quran Oh what is this
you know well first of all the angel
said they recited a seven so we didn't
make it up right imagine like the Bible
saying the angel came and says 360 you
can recite in whichever way you do it
you know it's all the Bible you know
what I mean it doesn't work like
we have the revelation that tells us
this is the or you know the angel
jibreel said recited in this way any of
them is the truth yeah so this is you
have not just Muslim scholarship
confirming this you have non-muslim
academics people who don't have this
nefarious agenda evil intent who are
truly academics who've studied this they
have confirmed this also is that correct
of course yeah of course and to go back
to what the brother says about image as
a he does not say that he was confused
and doubt about the carrot or the roof
he was about the meaning what does the
actual mean like what are these seven
things you know how is it changing or
how is it in you know seven ways okay
that's what it was it was not that he's
like in doubt or he doesn't know what it
is or anything and that is why you'll
find even in the scholarship of the
people right that there is a
misunderstanding some people use the
word cara some people use the word roof
and some people said they're the same so
that's where a lot of confusion came
amongst it but bottom line guys going
back to just simple logic reason and of
course proof and evidence the angel came
to the prophet sala service and recite
the quran on two three four seven ways
which ever way you recited it is the
truth yeah okay and and when you look at
it what the Prophet SAW said What did he
say what did he say why did he say just
don't keep it to one why he said I'm our
send to a nation of illiterate and
literal of old and young it's going to
be difficult for them they will not be
able to okay so that's why there was a
flexibility in the revelation not that
it changed the meaning the words that
this that is basically can you compare
it like the intercept look at look at
this just that you're in love for
asalaam just increases it's amazing him
interceding look as a mercy for the
prayer and even for his Ummah here can
you make that that yeah because you see
the previous scriptures were so hard to
be preserved why again for the same
reason there was knowledgeable people
there's ignorant people those so the
preservation of the previous scriptures
they were corrupted and it was on to
people and the process of Salem is
asking the Angels it's gonna be
difficult for people to recite the Quran
only one way number one I know that this
is not the correct interpretation but
amongst the Arabs there are so many
different dialects so many different
pronunciation and yes even amongst the
Quran and there's certain things that
are linked to that to the different
dialects of the earth this is not what
the Quran means because some have said
that Giraud or a growth means dialects
of the Arabs no but it's linked to that
in many cases okay so some Arabs cannot
pronounce certain words in a certain way
I'm just giving you as basic you know
crude explanation you know as to why the
mercy was there but again people be like
oh you're just giving us some
explanation it's not evidence
it's evidence because the angel came in
the authentic hadith and said one two
three four five six seven it would be an
explanation if there's no text no
evidence to say that there is this way
of reciting Quran and I will be
injecting it into the scripture and try
to come up with next like the Trinity
there is no such thing as the Trinity in
the Bible people try to pick from here
and from there instead of extracting
theology from text which you should
people are trying to inject theology
into it and that's what's called
interpolation of or the hadith
yes changing the scripture so let's
close with this so we said okay
confirmation we have the Quran even even
the in the individual who some of this
controversy came from he also concluded
this is that we have the Quran as it was
as it was revealed we have it today
preserved from the crater heavens an
earth we even have which we don't even
need but you have a Western academics
also confirmed this and then when you
you also made some contrast with the
Quran this is not with the Bible there's
nothing like for instance where you have
the RSV version talking about the King
James Version has grave defects so many
and so serious as to call for a revision
in many of the Gospels towards the end
you have chunks and chunks of verses in
this version and this is what I'll do
respect to our Christian friends and
neighbor just is making a contract this
is like Christian scholars tell us this
people of course call the gospel books
Matthew Mark Luke and John well they
call the Matthew Mark Luke and John
because we don't know who wrote these
books and there's no point calling them
Sam Fred Jerry and Harry I mean they're
they're written by people we don't know
who they were written by they are
anonymous you might not think so because
they have the title the Gospel according
to Matthew whoever put that title on it
was an editor later the followers of
Jesus were Aramaic speaking peasants
from Galilee lower-class men who were
not educated in fact Peter and John in
Acts chapter 4 verse 13 are literally
said to be illiterate they couldn't read
and write of course not they were
fishermen they didn't go to school the
vast majority of people in the ancient
world never learned to read let alone
write and their native language was
Aramaic these books are written in Greek
by highly educated rhetorically trained
writers who are skilled in Greek
composition they come out academics this
is nothing hidden like the Muslim world
is just coming out and talk they we get
this from them they're telling us
matthew didn't write matthew luke didn't
write Luke John these books are
anonymous so chunks and chunks are out
from this version this is put it in this
one you cannot this is totally because
if you take one ayah from the Quran put
another one in or what not like you gave
this greater now this story from this
person and people called it out we don't
have nothing like that yes exactly
nothing like it and just add to the and
if we're in last last thing last thing
go ahead finish your point I'm gonna I'm
gonna conclude one final course you just
world by the time
to the two regular folks on their
brothers and sisters who might be in
doubt remember one point that sadly and
the brother it did he didn't mention his
book but again you're responsible you
might have changed the pay I don't know
but you have to understand this religion
has been preserved to the east not okay
this nod is something that sort sorry to
say even Western academia cannot come
close to okay because in the Western
academia sorry any Tom Dick in here you
can go and take a masters or a PhD or
you know have open up a YouTube channel
or do some research and contradict other
researches and I've done research on
Parkinson's and to be honest you know at
one point our professors and just fudge
the results I'm gonna be a very
straightforward about that okay so
people need to understand also the world
of research just because his research
doesn't know people like Oh science
shows or research shows that's it's like
the Word of God you know what I mean
it's done because you're not there you
don't understand what's going on in the
labs you don't understand what
hypothesis and what you're doing and how
what you look reaching the conclusion
and there are a lot of time we call it
fudging results okay because it's just a
bit simpler than having to remake it
you're gonna lose funding there's gonna
be problems people are gonna question
you sometimes you just look at the
literature review and you confirm
something that might be part of it okay
and anyone who's in research can vouch
for it of course there's academic
integrity and there's a lot of cases and
people are called for plagiarism you can
validate they can look at any of this
the Quran has been preserved through D
is not okay what this brothers saying
about the different rod every single
Quran or recitation has an is not a map
that goes straight to the prophet
sallallahu alayhi wasallam okay and that
you need to understand meaning every
single person we know who they are who
was their teacher who is their father
what's their name how old their were how
they pray they were good they were this
their that every single one going up to
the Sahaba we learn
from the process of Salem who learned
from Gabriel in angel jibreel we learn
from allah subhanaw taala
this is the east and for every single
quran
okay are the ten authentic ones okay and
that goes up to that so it's not like
the Bible it's not like just yeah let's
just put it all together and it's the
same thing it's not no science in this
world has the concept of it's not no
educational institution no system in
this world when it comes to knowledge
has the concept of it's not with its
science in more region who are these
human beings not only have they actually
gotten the knowledge but who were they
were these people of integrity were
these people who were good imagine any
if your house would be burned down or
something would happen which is a
natural thing it's an act of God people
say in the West right okay
hadith or even knowledge people would
not accept why because there's a small
doubt that there might have been some
compromise ation of your notes or your
knowledge or something like that huh to
the point a mime card when you went to
remove hadith from some what the guy was
calling his horse and he was faking that
he's saying come come I'm gonna give you
something and he traveled for months and
he saw that and he said if he's gonna
fool his horse he is gonna fall Imam
harder this is the level of strictness
when it comes to academic integrity okay
goes and when it comes to the Quran and
the Sunnah so with all due respect to
anyone it doesn't matter what they
aren't because in the end these are just
people Allah so parent I said in the
National nesland and dhikr
why would I have hit on he has sworn and
yes I know the brother believes that I'm
not saying it doesn't but you have to be
careful of what you live and what you
leave unaddressed and unattended because
a lot of people are listening a lot of
people don't have knowledge have not
read all these books that's why Allah
sent prophets to speak to people in
their language at their level and with
all due respect
sadly being infatuated by this Western
academia today some of our Muslim
brothers are speaking and giving
lectures than it goes here
and they think that people are listening
and they're understanding well with all
due respect we're using some terminology
that some people have to look it up in
the dictionary and that is not the
prophetic way sometimes the process have
used to explain the words even the
Sahaba used to ask them you know so what
does this word mean and used to explain
it okay but today a lot of people think
that one so educated I'm coming from
this University and so on and they're
speaking in such a high way in such an
articulate way in such a complex way I'm
bringing from this one and that one in
this book and a book and everyone's kind
of sitting there Wow amazing but it
might be confusing people it might be
confusing people so our mother sisters
need to understand that the Quran it's
not only preserved it has the highest
highest authenticity when it comes to
academic integrity to knowledge the way
it's been passed on the way it's been
preserved every single way a recitation
goes back to the Sahaba and to the
prophets allah allah they are memorize
there are brothers who know the whole
ten different citations even the ones
and that's another thing guys the fact
that we have not authentic hadith and
not authentic recitations goes to show
that the system filtrates it out wow
this is amazing good point okay you have
to understand the fact that we have
fabricated week and so on hadith and
Quran goes to show that the system
filtrate said out there scholars have
written books just on fabricate happy
just on and by the way the scholars of
quran' they memorized even the weak ones
and they know even and they know the
mistake and where the issue is and where
it's been gone wrong okay and it's all
available there it's not me and you ND
or any one brother this
they're going beyond some closed doors
discussing in an email group and trying
to make it like wow you know it's only
for private information this should not
go to the public because this shocks the
people or what are you guys hiding in a
private email group for only for
students of knowledge you know like come
on man that's like not very nice I would
say look let's us conclude with this
tell me so
confirming in closing that if you were
to take all of the books out there of
any kind of religion from the Bible to
the Vedas from any anything out there
just imagine any book that you have any
text and you put it in a locked safe
burned it got rid of it and now you got
to bring some of these books back would
the Quran be probably the only book that
you would be able to bring back from any
of these books and would we be able to
do that with the Quran because you'd
have you'd have to start on you'd have
to start with a blank piece of paper so
would we be able to bring it back like
we have it today it's not probably is
the only one 100% no 100% no doubt about
it no doubt there there is no other law
awkward well I'm hungry that can't be
memorize no doubt brother no 100% and
Allah says it's not because me and you
like to say that it's because Allah says
well Akkad yes sir or analytically we
have made the Quran easy for you to
remember you take a half is from Bosnia
one from Romania from from China one
from Pakistan one from Timbuktu one from
I don't know where Finland and you put
them together and they will put the
Koran back within a few days word for
word sentence for sentence ayah for I
and if you don't believe me okay go to
any mosque pray behind any Imam make a
mistake in the Quran and see how fast
you'll be corrected all of you have
experienced this all of you you cannot
change the Quran it's not what the
question is not whether the Quran has
been changed or has different variations
Coran the question is can the Koran be
changed even today no it cannot
impossible
so if he cannot be changed today it
wasn't you cannot change yesterday and
you cannot change it a month ago and a
hundred years ago and 1000 years ago it
still could not be changed but today I
can change the Bible and still people
are changing it as we're talking and so
did they 100 years ago and so did they
500 oh and because that's the nature you
cannot change something it's nature and
the nature of the Quran is that it's
unchangeable Delhi Calcutta la vie Buffy
again clarification and disclaimer I do
not believe the brother believes the
Koran is change no that's not what I'm
saying he doesn't believe that
okay people need to respect the brother
and what he's done he starts so much he
has done so much good for this Ummah
okay yes he is someone a good man
he is a very respectful and has good add
up and good manners and very nice person
overall okay so people need to be
careful if your Allah with the way they
talk to him and so on so having said
that the brother does not believe the
fir'aun's being changed whatsoever this
goes to the Christians as well who might
try to take his statements okay out of
context this goes to the Muslims who
might be confused he does not believe
the Quran astray he makes it very clear
people have to be careful not to pick
and choose from his statements he makes
it very clear that he believes the Quran
is preserved he cites the verses okay
where he's done a mistake and I'm not
scared to say the sun's day isn't
explaining what he means and leaving
people and obscurity when it came to
this group that has this so-called
hidden you know talks or hidden
discussions and you know that there's
another group that he has with different
scholars trying to explain what these
things mean and this is not something
for the public and this is all in the
books of Islam these people go to
university to study karate and often and
they still today and many even in the
West we go to to Michigan University
any of the Islam online any of these
universities you know can study and
these issues okay this is not something
for a hidden group or some esoteric
knowledge that only some people are and
he failed to clarify some of those
statements and sadly that has left
people with some confusion people may
email me and have asked me to clarify
this and talk about it and so on again
he's a great brother-in-law you know
protect him humming and and and guide
him but sadly the environment has had a
huge toll on him in studying and the
university Neal has had a huge dollar he
himself says so he shouldn't feel I
apologize if he feels he sees this and
he feels offended but he himself has
said that he's gone through a crisis and
I feel bad for him that he's gone
through that crisis and he should
rectify that and remember his initial
training because it starts with that you
know with you need a decal kita
holography this is the book there's no
doubt
Semyon all Tana we hear we obey allah
subhanaw taala is unseen and he we
believe in him so shouldn't be strange
that there's ya'juj and ma'juj somewhere
hiding behind the wall shouldn't be
strange that cows speak or the trees
speak or anything like that it's very
clear so panel I know people in this
technology world in this world of the
phones and everything it's funny that we
we cannot comprehend such things go
fifty years ago if you would have told
someone that you can put the whole
library of Cambridge University on a USB
they would have locked you up man they
would have put you in an asylum and say
you crazy right but we know that on a
thumb drive you can put the whole
library of Chicago if you have to on a
small thumb drive you know what I mean
so people need to understand where to
put their reason and mind and rationale
in relationship to revelation and sadly
his research is you know on this topic
and so panel on you know everyone makes
a mistake and definitely is made one and
I'm not scared to say that I pray to
Allah stronger to protect him I mean I
the army I pray to Allah to bless him
more in knowledge and
for him to reexamine his views because
people are listening to him people youth
people who want to learn we're in this
respect there listening to him do
everything is saying and he's not saying
people that he's endorsing online who
are supporting things that are against
Islam in the name of you know supporting
marginalized groups this is a problem as
well because the Prophet SAW son says
when can i you mean to be like my ami
laughter finally awkward hi
oh yes mam if you believe in Allah and
the last day say something good or just
keep quiet no one is forcing you to
share platform with people who are
fighting Islam or you know some subtle
way or indirect way but they are trying
and our children are suffering
our children are slowly changing their
sexuality they're changing the way
they're looking at things and they're
looking to see oh but chicks also said
that it's like you know it's like I live
in this place it's my right to do
whatever I want
you know no gluten is a lamb did not go
and say to the people it's your right to
do whatever you want he kept calling
them he kept telling them he wanted to
offer his own daughters for God's sake
in marriage to the people right and keep
in mind you know this was not just
something that people were bored with
the whole village was like that because
it is an issue of getting used to it and
being nurtured okay if you study the
whole psychology behind it and you look
at the evidence and look at things this
is something that if people are not
going to talk and join hands and discuss
sadly it's gonna come true so there's
responsibility on the ulama in the West
to to you know to really guide our youth
and our communities not to stay silent
and to share platforms in hope that our
new our Muslims will not leave Islam or
that they can stop people from leaving
Islam you cannot stop people from
leaving Islam people will leave Islam
because it's allah subhanaw taala who
looks at their arts and as allah says
he says you did Ljubica 0db
yo mama you didn't to be ill and fast
you keen he is guys many buy it by the
Quran and he guides many by it by the
Quran but he does not misguide except
the evildoer the fasiqun the people of
say so in the end it is very clear
may Allah protect us protect us o MA and
maybe we will be a sort source of
guidance for the for all of humanity
because we're sharing this out of the
love thank you so much I'm here for may
this be a benefit to the people and
shall I'll be able to clear up any
doubts that someone might have had with
certainty yakeen
delivering this truth thank you very
much my brother I love you
[Music]
[Music]